we talk about stories that have impact
versus stories that entertain what are
the two difference what are the
similarities I mean this is the kind of
core of what catharsis is about you know
we called our company catharsis because
this is a word that Aristotle uses in
the poetics to talk about what story
really should be in people and in
society a great story should lead people
to a cathartic revelation a new
understanding it should open a new
insight for them it should change them
in a good way
and that as we brood over stories
together as a society together which we
change in a good way you know that
stories help us clarify our values they
help us decide what is heroic behavior
what is dastardly behavior you know that
stories allow us to process this when
they're good stories that that they lead
to social catharsis unfortunately too
many stories that are being produced
today and I hate to use the word story
you know because they really aren't
doing that at all the core purpose of
story they're they're more conceived as
a product to sell by the the
entertainment industry you know to be
much more like a an amusement park ride
right so we're gonna make image of em's
literally you know but it's like well
let's just take two hours for people and
make them go and then it's over and then
they walk out after two hours and
fourteen bucks and or thirty bucks for
popcorn coke and and then the movie
right and and the question is what did I
get from that what is any residual
benefit to me for my life did I get from
that now too many movies the answer is
nothing really nothing that it was
conceived to be like like cotton candy
or a you know and a amusement park ride
and that that's all it was meant to do
it got you there for opening weekend you
plunk down your cash and now you're done
with it and it's done with you we aspire
to encourage writers to have a much more
noble purpose than just distracting
people for two hours kind of coke
people into the theater to plunk down
some money you know the contract with
the audience for us is we're going to
give you something really worth your
time that that we're gonna pour gonna
give you something that might help you
on your journey so when you go into the
theater you have your to our experience
of thrills and chills
but it's what you're it's and that's
fine but what it's what you're left with
as you leave the theater that you're
chewing on that is that moment of
catharsis that that we want to have for
the audience to experience and so it's
and that often has to do with the ending
and it's final image and and what the
audience is walking away digesting after
having experienced this movie so that
it's not just a two-hour event it's an
event that becomes ingrained into the
rest of their lives and it's something
that they're thinking about the question
for the writer is not what you're gonna
say to the audience in your movie but
what the audience is gonna say to
themselves after this movie you know I
remember a story of one guy that I heard
where he saw Finding Nemo with his
little boy and his wife and he's this
you know big guy he was a marine and you
know not really a philosopher but
they're in the truck driving home after
finding Nemo and and he said to his wife
you know babe Emily a good dad you know
and I think that to me is a cathartic
story you know he watched this movie so
enjoyable so delightful so clever and
creative but at the end it provoked him
to ask himself am i a good dad and want
to talk about that this is what we need
and it doesn't happen by accident you
know the writer has to have something to
say has something to give something to
share something to propose that we
should brood over in their concept and
and then then that gives this meat to
the project there's just too many
projects that are not solid meat there's
just nothing there there's nothing
really worth sharing and it's
intentionally done that way you know
I've been in unfortunately the Hollywood
development system militates against
something meaty because they're nervous
that it will turn people off right
people we don't we don't want to put
anything in the movie that might make
people think you know that might make
people
you know have to you know have to you
know maybe though they won't like it
maybe they won't get it they and
conversely they they they don't shy away
from controversy but they don't but they
do is shy away from meaning from meaning
yeah and so this is a I think today the
challenge for somebody as a storyteller
today is just shake that off shake off
that I'm here just to create some
sausage you know that's the word they
use in Hollywood for story it's like
we're generating sausage it's like no
we're not we're generating story story
is a beautiful noble important thing
it's critical to a good society and it's
very broken right now so we want
storytellers to kind of really reclaim
their noble purpose the storyteller used
to be in ancient societies right next to
the chief and the priest as the most
important person in the society because
they were gonna lead the society to
really look at itself to grow and deepen
we need to get that back nobody right
now would think that Hollywood
storytelling is like you know leading
our society to deepen and grow that's
pathetic and it starts with the writer
and sometimes the writer is the only
person in the room who will champion
that and and and that's okay as so long
as the writer continues to be somebody
who champions that it won't be
completely off the table when did it
change you said today so it sounds like
of a different era different years 70s
80s maybe years ago it was it was still
around yeah I mean I think that there
were two central changes one was when
Hollywood gone up or broken up the
studio system got broken up in the
post-war period and basically it went
from being movies made by people who
love movies to movies made by
corporations the second thing that
happened was the blockbuster period a
little movie about a shark you know was
shot for eight million dollars or so and
made a you know a billion dollars and
then it was like wow more shark right
you know so the blockbuster period
became this kind of very formulaic model
of a hero driven you know a spectacle
driven project and when we say spectacle
we mean spectacle right you know that
something weird and cool to
see and and that trumped then the inner
story you know the the story of the
characters transformation and so that's
what we've seen you look at these just
like scads and scads and scads of these
comic book movies or these you know
big-budget action nothing's right and
they're they're just about that they're
about providing two hours of spectacle
and it's about let's you know we'll make
this movie for a hundred million and
it'll make five hundred million and and
that's that's all it's about it's a
product to be sold
it's about coaxing the audience into
opening weekend and and and there's no
concern for what well what is this story
really saying so the writer has to have
enough confidence in themselves and
their vocation to say no you know I'm
not just making sausage I want to make
something that will leave my world and
the people in my audience in a better
place and so we're fine producers who
also resonate with that find you know
new we want to you know really
Renaissance in this in this storytelling
industry it's gonna start with the
writers and it can happen on the big
studio level and you'll see that the
story there are some that make their way
through there
that have both and and ultimately they
end up doing much better at the box
office anyway I'm just thinking back to
ET I mean I know that that's a
blockbuster from many years ago there
were the toys there were all the things
that went with it but there was still
that that emotional part and beautiful
story about a coming-of-age movie
I mean coming-of-age movies is almost a
dead genre right now what does that say
you know we we've lost even the faith to
say that you would go on a growth
journey as a young person you know we
don't want to say that anymore there's
almost no coming-of-age movies I think
that's what makes boyhood so fresh it's
like wow we haven't seen a coming-of-age
story for so long so I think that that
the storytelling is broken we just have
to acknowledge it it's broken and and we
need to look back to the classical era
I think the classical nature story we
have to look back to move forward and
that we have to read say no story has a
nature humanity has it has a nature and
and they have to work together we're
going to reclaim the purpose of story in
our society
and really start to bring people back to
the the movies again and so that they
walk out and say you know that was cool
like that one I want to talk to people
about and that's what makes a classic
that's what makes it last for 50 hundred
years
you